you guys were talking a moment ago about
you know like you your fan base flipped
on you you want to explain like what
happened you guys were doing Fitness
content on YouTube and yeah it used to
be very young
you see a bunch of bodybuilders yeah and
fit chicks it was a good uh mix it's
like yeah
15 20 would be like black probably yeah
I mean we'll we've always had a majority
white audience because we live in a
white country but it was a good mix it
was a it showed it it uh it represented
what America is right now it's just yeah
like it looks like we had a Bruce
Springsteen concert there's a whole
bunch of white dudes yeah when I it it
totally blew me away because when we had
a show in Knoxville we look out to the
arms I was like Club rolls cowboy hats
us like I think these people at the
wrong yeah yeah I didn't know I mean I
mean since we came out of the closet
that's concerned but I didn't think it
was I thought
for the most part we was committing
career suicide but we just fed up we was
just so pissed off by how the direction
of the country and yeah and then but
then we had no idea people was going to
come out and support us the way they did
you know what's crazy when we go out
before our comedy shows we get a
standing ovation wow yeah so you guys
actually thought it was done you're like
we're gonna say this that's the end of
it yeah yeah I had no idea it was going
to take off the way it did there's the
best decision we ever made you know it's
a lot of places they want books because
we're conservative but the comedy clubs
that do book us man the staff the uh the
management activity like man these
people are tipped so good you guys can
come back it's like they spend money
they tip well they're real uh cultural
for everybody and then there's some
clubs to where they treat our fans like
[ __ ] I never go back there wow yeah yeah
I want to give a shout out to uh ex-cal
shooting range and fitness and uh sports
fitness shooting in uh Virginia we went
there this weekend everyone there was
super cool if you're like shooting guns
man shout out because they were very
very nice to us yeah super awesome I
hope so they got Goods that's right
that's right and I'm like I don't don't
think I think if you're if you're in a
position where you're in the business of
guns you you've you've got to choose
your friends as loudly as possible
because if you're not speaking up for
your rights they've been coming after
you for a long time yeah an armed
Society is a very polite society and
yeah I I think you know the stats in
Chicago especially with crime uh show
that very well yeah uh but yeah shouts
out to xcal great guys uh great facility
uh lots of firearms lots of like really
fun stuff to shoot full auto yeah I had
a lot of fun there this weekend as well
so what's your favorite gun what's your
favorite paper
um it depends I mean what are we doing I
mean 300 Blackout uh sugar weasels are
also pretty cool
I'm a body guy I got a shotgun they had
a they have cameras on the range right
and I'm walking out to grab some of our
our crew to bring them in and I and I'm
like oh there's Luke and you can see
Luke in the camera in the range and you
can't hear anything and he's just going
like this yeah like explaining the
machine gun but uh but the reason I I
was asking about is because I mentioned
earlier that we're gonna do this big
skate thing uh on Saturday I shouldn't
even call it a big skate thing I just
said literally I'm gonna go and skate
because you know I'm just sick and tired
of hearing this over and over and over
again and look I got a lot of friends
who are in the skateboard industry that
people I've known for decades people
have known since I was a kid and they're
all doing this thing where they're like
hey man I really agree with everything
you say but like I I you know I can't I
can't tell anybody that of course and
I'm like I'm like I hate that get out of
here dude like look that's like such a
smacking so what happened what what uh
what galvanized you to do this event
with the skateboard well look man like
I don't want to call an event I'm just
gonna say okay I'm gonna be there so
we've gone skating around all the parks
in this area right never had an issue
they opened up a new park to a park in
Hagerstown Maryland no issue I show up
I'm skating people come up to me they're
fist bumping me they're shaking my hands
they're like oh dude like cool man cool
this is really awesome then I go to DC
and apparently like something happened I
don't even know what because I don't
really even know anybody there well it's
DC that's DC yeah but it's all money my
own business and there was like a couple
people that I I like one guy sort of
knew and there are a couple people there
who are like you know famous and I'm
just like oh wow look at this guy and
I'm just like talking to locals no
problem but apparently some people had
some some beef and started like sending
out texts into the into the community
saying something I don't even know
exactly what necessarily listen because
you're white yeah yeah yeah actually
they were wider than I was right and so
uh they were The Good Wife that's right
that's how it goes right so me being uh
you know like supposedly this diverse
visual of a mixed race background
showing up to skate my own business I
got white people attacking me now but
I'm the white supremacist that bad guys
but so I was just like dude
I live here man we live in the DC area I
skate here there's no reason for
anything to be said about anything I'm
on my own business I'm gonna go do what
I want I'm gonna skate I'm do what I
want yeah and so the issue is you guys
mentioned that your audience flipped it
I thought that was interesting for me
what's what's happened is I found that
most of the people who followed me
still do but they message me probably be
like oh yeah I just can't I can't I
can't let anybody know and then I'm like
here's gonna happen
there's a little kid right now he's 10
years old
he's not heard of free speech at all
because you won't speak up so when he
goes to the skate park the only thing he
hears is wokeness right and then you
just keep your mouth shut like a good
little like a good little endangered
servant marching behind behind the woke
people it was helping them to their ends
I'm not going to do that yeah that's
what feeds it nobody's speaking up
that's right so that's that's that's
that's kind of uh you know Bravo you
guys demanded um just because you might
have different opinions in politics
while people will
I don't know it's just it's just it's a
cult yeah it's a lack of courage in this
country but it's like it seems like it's
when people get afraid when they start
to panic is when the politics becomes
divisive if they're not in a panic state
right I've never noticed that in the
last 40 years right you're absolutely
fun it's actually fun to talk politics
yeah yeah and that's why I think your
story your guys's story is so important
here because you know you guys also had
that fear before coming out and actually
being the truest versions of yourselves
being actually authentic not being
afraid to actually speak your mind and
once you're living freely there's
there's the kind of softness there's a
kind of easiness going around life being
like hey I'm not gonna have to you know
think about what I'm gonna have to say
here I'm just gonna say what I want you
to say living that life is amazing and
sadly a lot of people listening to this
right now are holding themselves back
they're afraid to say anything they're
afraid to intervene they're afraid to
have those conversations and I think
they're being stupid yeah right yeah
it's a liberating experience once you do
come out I mean it's liberating for a
gay person to finally come out of the
closet is liberating if you're
conservative just come out and be
yourself it was definitely liberating
for two black guys to come out of the
closet yes conservative so what happened
leading up to it were you getting
frustrated
I got tired of looking at like all these
uh famous black people on social media
with their views I was like man I have a
platform I'm gonna use my platform to
express you know I'm a black guy but I
think this way it's like it's almost
like a culture within a black communion
it is it's like 90 of blacks vote
Democrat every election that is so weird
there's no other demographic in this
country that votes at that clip that
ninety percent yeah it doesn't make it
cost to think the other side is racist
they fail for that yeah what they say
and they keep saying that people on the
left that said uh that we are a threat
to democracy the only threat to the
market is when you lie about the other
side and call them names and uh call
them transphobia racist they are the
threats to democracy because you're
lying for votes for the federal
government to prosecute them and to
silence their speech on social media
like the White House is doing by
literally telling social media companies
to censor people because of their voices
let me just say that kind of democracy
is like North Korean democracy yeah they
call it the Democratic People's Republic
of North Korea and they all vote and
they all have to vote for the one guy
yeah when you all vote for the exact
same thing that's not democracy yeah so
but here's what you got to understand
when they say you're a threat to our
democracy they're not talking about the
United States as an hour they're talking
about the cult as an hour they're saying
you're a threat to the woke order that's
what they're saying and when they're
calling for diversity they're not
calling for diversity of opinions yeah
right they're just calling for diversity
of the same opinion that they're going
to regurgitate and beat you over the
head with because that's the power
structure that really is kind of
fomenting in this country and getting
more violent and getting more powerful
by the day which is becoming a larger
threat against human
that's why they picked a black woman to
be a jugs because she's a woman and when
she gets up and she doesn't know what
the hell a woman is there was a BS this
woman uh Kirsten Henning I think her
name was she refused to kneel for BLM
and it was a college soccer I think and
uh so they benched her because of it she
just won 100 allegedly she filed a
lawsuit 100 Grand she since left she's
on doing her life hundred thousand
dollars in her pocket nice so I'm
telling people there there was this
college professor who said if you're in
school if you're in work and they start
disparaging white people Christians
males or any of that stuff or
conservatives bring it to HR and file a
complaint because they're not allowed to
do that use their own system against
them like Blackstone protected class
gays are protected class any person of
color is a protected class but I don't
think necessarily you can be
discriminatory towards white people and
you don't have to worry about any civil
rights yeah that's right so what they're
doing yeah yeah that's the culture of
the United States of America right now
which is weird because it's the idea
that a white person has no color it's a
person that isn't no they're saying that
colors did you're actually what they're
saying you are superior yeah yeah thanks
yeah
all right but the best day of my life
this is how um as a black person yeah
I'm telling you that's where it comes
from yeah they think you're Superior I
think it comes from a lot of self-hatred
too they don't think they can do it
because they've been they've been
indoctrinated black person you turn on
TV and you need a white politician
Democrat to help you be successful in
this country that's what Joe Biden said
they want to put y'all back in Chains
yeah I mean 90 that's why 90 of black
people vote Democrat because they think
they need Democrats up because you guys
are evil and are you sure you guys are
black because Joe Biden said if you're
not voting for him you're not really
particularly I'm no longer black exactly
so yeah were you guys feeling like the
racism percolate before you got vocal
politically were you feeling that kind
of stuff because it was like under the
radar until 2016. I didn't I wasn't
sensing it I actually did a president
who actually converted me was was uh
Barack Obama he'd actually converted me
I thought when he became president
because I voted for him for his first
term you know I voted for Al Gore I
voted for Bill Clinton I was raised
Democrats I voted for Kerry
but you know what I just like yeah yeah
when I went that Skull and Bones cousin
yeah Barack Obama actually changed her
minds and first time I voted Republican
was for Mitt Romney yeah believe that
[ __ ] like like Barack some people have
said he's the was the most racist
president of all time because he would
constantly talk about race yeah yeah
yeah yeah I thought it was a great thing
when he got elected I was like man this
is yeah you would thought like man black
man is President how far has this
country came in ever since he yeah
turn for the worse in this country this
country is systemically racist but even
though a black man beat two white men in
a country that's what 65 white yeah with
the name Baraka Hussein Obama yeah and
twice yeah
a galvanized white supremacist attack on
the Rocks Barack Obama not my country
I mean it just it doesn't make anything
yeah the porter in Chief that's right
everyone forgot I mean if you voted for
Romney that's technically technically
voting for a Democrat too so yeah yeah
well he was my last name yeah McCain the
same way looking back on it now looking
back on it dude do it feel like it was a
setup for him to become president that's
the best thing the Republicans could
admit Romney and McCain yeah it doesn't
I mean or they're just not smart people
right but the thing is they're they're
two Elite clubs and they're able to keep
everybody out but they were friends with
Obama of course of course and he was
calling him pretty basically a racist
and they didn't even you see that weird
you see the video from uh from the house
when there's no speaker C-SPAN can show
whatever they want and you've got
Republicans and Democrats fist bumping
and hanging out yeah yeah yeah and then
but then you know many of these people
get up and be like oh these people
across the aisle they don't wanna hey
man I'm just saying that you know it's
all one big thing it's like George
Collins said I kind of feel like we
stuck in The Truman Show yeah man I feel
that that's for sure yeah especially on
mushrooms
tragic yeah it's the um all the
artificial stuff is very obviously built
by humans everything else is like what
is this reality thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time